ich zeige euch heute mal drei
verschiedene arten wie ihr granatäpfel
entfernen können bei der ersten variante
entfernt den deckel und den boden des
granatapfels hier schneidet jetzt
entlang der kammer so könnt ihr jetzt
den granatapfel aufspalten die äußere
haut entfernen und die kerne ganz
einfach raus lösen für variante 2
braucht ihr am besten irgend einen
großen schweren gegenstand paar mädchen
granatapfel schneidet aber bitte nur die
schale ein öffnet ihn und legt dann den
halben granatapfel mit der schnittfläche
nach unten in eurer hand jetzt klopft
ihr mit dem schweren gegenstand auf die
schale und die granatapfel gerne fallen
durch eure hand herunter für die dritte
variante halb werde den granatapfel
wieder nicht durchschneiden sondern nur
die schale an riffen und dann könnt ihr
unter wasser die granatapfel kern heraus
lösen ihr habt dann auch die weiße haut
die könnt ihr ganz einfach auslösen ihr
habt aber den kleinen nachteil und zwar
den dass der ganze granatapfelsaft ein
bisschen verloren wird so einfach geht's
1 2 oder 3 letzte chance vorbei schreibt
wir doch gerne mal ob ihr variante eins
zwei oder drei bevorzugt beim
granatapfel entkernen